I'm Brandon Walker and I oversee sports
marketing in North America for
basketball career day is an opportunity
for our legacy student-athletes from
Chicago to have a chance to have
hands-on learning and training with the
best from our industry from design to
Footwear to apparel to eSports we've
done it all and have a chance to give
them some hands-on learning today and so
our goal was for our student athletes to
reimagine their future and visualize
themselves as something more than they
thought when they arrived so they got to
be next to their idols while actually
getting this chance to look behind the
curtain the legacy program is a high
school basketball program that's
designed to tonight empower and uplift
the community and what we do is we go
into high school basketball programs
that need us the most
so we're going we're in LA if we expand
it to New York we're most recently in
Chicago we do more than just Deer they
get the best gear but we figured what
better way to reach the community than
leverage our resources to empower impact
lives career day is us embodying change
as a team sport by bringing the best
from our brand and putting them in the
exact same room with our legacy
student-athletes